well if I've read correctly I understand
you took a hiatus and came back in
nineteen seventy if that's correct and
that you usually wanted to be
attentional hiatus nobody nobody wanted
me it's it's like I was a child and no
more a child so as a and they wanted a
kid and I was not that cute kid anymore
so I had to wait that long it was
fifteen years not 15 10 years so I
trained all the while and trained as a
dancer in classical dancing I did a bit
of singing and stuff like that so and I
am I'm glad that the industry was kind
and never allowed me to take another
hiatus so was through other people's
encouragement and saying you should
really be up there and working your way
from supporting to then storing oh yeah
and so many people it's unbelievable
that they're part of my life the part of
whatever a biography of am i right they
become so important part of my I mean I
can understand my brother being with me
but these are people came from nowhere
and became part of my life and I truly
believe that these are my family now
you